Ich bin heute bei den Heerestauchern, und
da sind sie schon!
Hallo Robert!
Ich bin beeindruckt. Lassen Sie uns ein bischen über diesen Job reden.
Was müssen wir wissen?
Wir bilden Kampfschwimmer und Pioniertaucher aus.
Die Aufgabe der Pioniertaucher ist es, Unterwasser zu arbeiten.
Wir können mit Schremmhämmern Steine bearbeiten,
wir können mit Motorsägen Holz bearbeiten.
Was sehe ich da jetzt gerade?
Einen Helmtaucher, der vorbereitet wird für
einen Tauchgang bis 40m Tiefe.
Was muss ich denn über die Kampfschwimmer
wissen?
Kampfschwimmer sind die amphibischen Kräfte
des Jagdkommandos.
Sie führen Unterwasserangriffe mit Minen
durch,
greifen Objekte in Landnähe an und führen Aufklärungsaufgaben durch.
Und das ganze vollkommen unbemerkt.
Wir haben Tauchgeräte, die mit Sauerstoff
betrieben werden, und die keine Blasen erzeugen.
Man sieht uns nicht kommen. Neptuns dunkle Söhne.
Ich wäre auch gerne ein dunkler Sohn Neptuns,
wie schaffe ich das?
Das kannst du mit uns machen.
Jetzt?Jetzt!
Bevor du ins Freiwasser kommst und eine Übung
mit uns machst, musst du noch ins Hallenbad.
Hallenbad ist gut, mag ich.
Die Übungen sind schon vorbereitet.
Ja.
Dann legen wir los!
Und ab!
Die Zeit läuft!
3. 2. 1. ab!
Unterwassermarsch.
Ein Ausbildner wird es dir vorzeigen.
Das ist das Spezialgerät für Kampftaucher,
da kommt keine Luft raus, die nach oben perlt und dich verrät.
Hallo Robert, Hallenbadphase erledigt.
Wir beginnen den Arbeitstauchgang mit unserem Helmtauchgerät.
Wow. Dan setzen wir das Ding einmal auf.
Ich habe meinen Pioniertaucherschnupperkurs jetzt fürs Erste einmal erledigt,
jetzt schauen wir uns an, wie es die Menschen machen, deren Profession das ist.
Was für ein irrer Tripp!
Vom Helicopter ins Wasser, Unterwasser zur Landezone, Landezone gesichert, dank der Kollegen.
Wir werden dann den Pionieren signalisieren, dass sie die Panzerigel wegräumen können.
Entertainer für Posseidon 01, kommen.
Hier Posseidon 01, kommen.
Landezone ist aufgeklärt und gesichert, ihr könnt nachrücken, Zeichen wird gesetzt.
Hier Posseidon 01, verstanden. Ende.
Viele werden sich gedacht haben: "Wie, das Bundesheer hat Taucher?".
Und was für welche!
Ich habe hier jetzt einen Einblick gewonnen, in eine unglaubliche Truppe.
Auf der einen Seite die Pioniere die Arbeiten, die schon am Land schwer sind,
auch Unterwasser, extrem genial erledigen.
Auf der anderen Seite die Kampfschwimmer, die, Stichwort "No bubbles no troubles",
sich unbemerkt nähern können und in jedem noch so schwierigen Einsatzgebiet zu Hause sind.
Und dann auch noch die beiden Verbände, die gemeinsam,
auf ein Ziel fokusiert, ihre Aufgaben erfüllen.
Das war eine irrsinnig tolle Erfahrung.
Aber Achtung, jeder der glaubt, dieser Job
wäre jeden Tag ein Abenteuer,
hat vollkommen Recht.
Haben wir Besuch?
Servus Robert.
Du hast das echt super gemacht!
Gratuliere dir ebenfalls, eine Sache fehlt
noch, das weißt du aber, oder?
Ich habe so einen Verdacht.
Wir taufen dich zum Heerestaucher!
Zum Heerestaucher?
Achtung Wasser!
Danke, reicht das?
Danke.